qu'est ce qui différencie tous les
vaccins contre le coc vite 19
ça c'est la grosse question pas mal de
différences entre les vaccins donc la
technique de la rn messager qui est une
première technique il ya la technique
classique c'est on prend un virus et on
la ténue ou alors on le duo carrément il
ya aussi la technique d'utiliser un
adénovirus pour ces pour cibler les
défenses immunitaires et pour lui
présenter aux défenses immunitaires le
virus sarr skov 2011 benteke moderna
utilise la rna messagers les vaccins
chinois utilisent un virus qui a été tué
le vaccin russe utilise un adénovirus
les vaccins d'astrazeneca aussi donc
chacun a sa technique
kaiser moderna et astrazeneca on a des
résultats en population donc qui permet
de voir que ça permet d'éviter les
formes graves et maintenant d'éviter la
transmission et pour les vaccins chinois
et le vaccin russe on a des essais de
phase 1 et 2 qui montre que sur
l'immunité cellulaire ça marche très
bien aussi il n'avait jamais fait de
l'accession avec un corps une amie russe
donc toutes les techniques pouvait être
justifiée
non